there's something better than perfection
according to this painting in the middle
of brantford 15 metres high the artists
team heritage our Philemon also known as
a cooled and yes means D key called
Halen
among the concrete skyscrapers their
image of a mother and a child stands out
from booty PES basically our work is
always a dialogue simply because we work
together we tell each other stories and
the way we use these walls or canvases
is like writing a diary we create our
own fantasy language to codify subjects
that interest us the work in Frankfurt
took just five days the images from
haiku its current project the giant
storybook project about two teenagers
living in a world of giants yet accout
were originally part of the graffiti
scene but now mostly spring walls only
were permitted this work was
commissioned by the local authorities to
prevent illegal graffiti and it's worked
Hajduk who are so well respected that
other graffiti sprayers have refrained
from altering the painting
if you come as the graffiti seemly come
from us usually a closed system it uses
a certain language that only graffiti
guys can understand and you communicate
with each other which makes it a
subculture but we develop this design to
communicate with a wide audience that's
when it turned into street art art in
public spaces was it's a street advert
as a Winston a fisherman arm
defied us in Debrecen house inside out
within the graffiti scene were both kind
of Outsiders because of the figurative
drawings and because Jasmine is a woman
in a male domain it's made us wary but
also given us more freedom to develop
our ideas ideas created on the spot she
designs the figures outlines he fills in
the details
he has creative illustrations and aku's
photorealistic spraying compliment each
other perfectly
Esmond works with different mediums the
spray can being one of them in our
projects I only use a spray I apply a
large color spectrum to give our
characters a three-dimensional effect
when they're done Gila as a motto that's
just come to mind great things have
small beginnings sketches and texts make
up the beginning of their new children's
book
they've already published two books
presenting a chronology of their work
together
Pina code can actually make a living
with her art they also sell Camus
paintings to galleries all over the
world but the street is their favorite
canvas this painting was created in
Toronto last year like all their works
that incorporates mystical even
melancholic elements it's usually the
things we think are important and worth
mentioning that end up with this serious
undertone but it doesn't mean they're
negative melancholy is like a state in
which you are completely open you have
one annoyed we want to give the people
something positive when we paint in
public spaces present them as something
positive to think about
new recruits have received invitations
to paint on walls all over the world
their clients range from urban art
festivals to individuals and celebrities
such as actor Jim Carrey the war can be
seen from Tel Aviv to Montreal from
Shanghai to San Francisco from Melbourne
to Kathmandu
the quartet in Agins middle it's big in
major cities street art is such a huge
movement because it's the only art
movement in history which is a global
phenomenon because of the internet your
BIOS that young people everywhere and
know about it and they're happy for us
to visit where they live
induced at Club the writing's on the
wall as our helices painted and sprayed
messages a welcome and colorful addition
to daily urban life